hi there steve kaufman here i guess i'm
day 10 into my korean challenge
uh today i want to talk about two things
one is distractions
and the other is uh how i'm dealing with
the difficulties of korean using
translations
distractions first of all i apologize no
video on saturday or sunday because as i
mentioned before my grandson is playing
hockey over on vancouver island
and it's an opportunity to get over
there see him and then play golf over
there because as you may know once we
get into the end of september october
here it starts to rain
and my wife is going to have a bunion
operation
and she'll be kind of unable to play
golf for quite a long time so we're
getting in as many golf games as we can
before that operation she gets her
operations on friday
uh so
uh with that you know playing golf
watching hockey traveling whatever
didn't really get much of a chance to do
a video i did
study however and that's the important
thing there's always distractions but
because i'm able to do it on my ipad and
even on my iphone i'm able to find
even a few minutes
10 minutes 15 minutes to do a bit of
reading and listening
however one of the problems with korean
for me is
that the structure is quite different
from
any well quite different from european
languages but even different from
japanese although there are similarities
and so very often i know the words and i
still can't really get a good sense of
what
the meaning is
and even though i'm not normally a big
fan of translations i am finding that
for the more difficult content that i'm
trying to learn from now
translations are helpful so you may know
i've mentioned that i enjoy listening to
kim yong-ha who is a korean writer who
has a very pleasant voice and who has a
podcast
and i kind of understand them when he
speaks
about a certain writer but when he reads
from the text i tend to get lost in a
hurry
so it so happens i think i may have
mentioned this that uh in uh lessons 22
and 23 at link because we had some of
his podcasts transcribed and
and imported as lessons
he in lesson 22 he talks about franz
kafka
and that part of it is more easily uh
you know understood by me
but then he starts to read from the
trial by franz kafka and that then
becomes more difficult
so i went online and found the english
text of the trial by franz kafka
i imported that as a translation into
the lesson so anyone who follows me to
that lesson will see the translation
there
and what's more because i bring the
translation in
to link i can actually separate it into
individual sentences or sometimes if
they're short two sentences at a time
because very often when we find the text
online it's all grouped together where
and then it's difficult to find where
you are so i've gone through now for
parts one and two
of lesson 23 which is the trial by franz
kafka where i have the audio read by kim
jung-ha who has a great voice
and i've gone through and saved words
and phrases still struggling to really
understand what they're talking about so
now i can go in and line by line compare
the korean to the english and i'm doing
it with
the trial which i haven't read before
by franz kafka so i think the idea first
of all
the fact that it's a translated book
from the original german
makes it probably a little easier
than something written originally in
korean insofar as literature is
concerned
uh and
second of all the fact that i'm able to
break it up now
line by line makes it easier for me so
that's what i'll be doing and i'll be
demonstrating some of that
uh
at a later date
um demonstrating how i use that link
uh
one other thing talking distractions uh
i have agreed now to do a webinar in
german
and so i now have to prepare a
presentation in german about language
learning and link and so forth and so on
so that's going to be a distraction that
will be on the 28th
at 10 o'clock vancouver time which i
think is nine in the that is ten o'clock
in the morning vancouver time not in the
evening
or was it seven i don't know
i will provide more information about
this so these are there are always
distractions and then i have my hockey
tournament coming up and of course my
wife's going to have this operation so
i've got to be looking after her there's
always distractions
but
if we are committed as i am
10 days into my 90 day challenge i've
just got to stay with it stay the course
thanks for listening bye for now